wie würde die welt heute aussehen wenn
niemand das internet erfunden hätte wie
sehr dein leben aus wenn du die letzten
zwei jahre nicht geraucht hätte und was
wäre eigentlich passiert wenn der mensch
keine daumen hätte nun für uns menschen
ist es nicht wirklich schwierig
zumindest zu mutmaßen was das für
auswirkungen hätte klar auch wir könnten
nur raten aber für die algorithmen sind
solche contra faktischen fragen also zum
beispiel was wäre wenn fragen
unglaublich schwierig und das deutet auf
eine der größten hürden in der aktuellen
ki forschung hin warum künstliche
intelligenz oft nur so tut als würde sie
dinge verstehen und wie forscherinnen
und forscher daran arbeiten das zu
ändern das erkläre ich euch jetzt schon
opel dann helfen nicht nur muster zu
erkennen sondern auch zusammenhänge zu
verstehen
das hier ist die zweite folge unserer
videoserie über kg in zusammenarbeit mit
dem max planck institut für intelligente
systeme und auch heute sprechen wir
wieder mit annika buchholz sie ist
physikerin und wissenschaftsmanagerin am
max planck institut in tübingen und
beschäftigt sich dort mit verschiedenen
aspekten des maschinellen lernens und
was das eigentlich alles beinhaltet das
könnt ihr euch hier in der ersten folge
unserer serie anschauen
in dieser folge möchte ich allerdings
eine ganz andere frage stellen und zwar
was ist eigentlich intelligenz und das
ist sicherlich keine einfache frage da
gibt es bestimmt verschiedene antworten
drauf aber eine wird dem uns
beschäftigen können ist ein modell von
judy appell an der mitbegründer der
kausalität im maschinen lernen die
leiter des chors einverständnis ist
phelps drei verschiedene stufen auf
stufe 1 ist das sehen das assoziative
verständnis also die straße ist nass es
hat also wohl geregnet
auf stufe zwei ist die fähigkeit
vorhersagen zu machen über aktionen also
wenn ich einen regenschirm auf stelle
damit die straße nicht nach so unter dem
schirm
und auf stufe 3 ist die fähigkeit
vorhersagen zu machen unter bedingungen
die sich nicht mehr ändern lassen oder
die nicht beeinflussbar sind wie zb wäre
die straße heute auch nass wenn wir vor
zehn jahren weniger co2 ausgestoßen
hätten und viele menschen hier auf stufe
drei und ein ganz klassisch geschrieben
des programms auf stufe 1 mit
maschinenlärm wollen wir eben auch für
205 3 kommen was in teilen schon möglich
ist zum beispiel im forschungsbereich
fairness
da geht es oft darum contra faktische
fragen zu beantworten zum beispiel hätte
ich den job auch bekommen wenn ich eine
andere hautfarbe oder ein anderes
geschlecht hätte wie verkehr ist das ist
übrigens das thema der nächsten folge
die im august ihr auf dem kanal kommt
heute wollen wir aber erst einmal
verstehen wie ein computer programm
lernen kann derart komplexe fragen zu
beantworten und wieso das verständnis
von 1000 zusammenhängen dafür eine
wichtige rolle spielt korrelation
bedeutet nicht automatisch kausalität
wenn ihr regelmäßig wissens videos hier
auf youtube guckt dann werdet ihr diesen
satz bestimmt schon öfter gehört haben
und es gibt eine menge beispiele die das
veranschaulichen die menge an gegessen
nach schokolade in einem land korreliert
zum beispiel mit der anzahl an
gewonnenen nobelpreisen das bedeutet
aber natürlich deswegen noch nicht dass
mehr schokolade einen auch intelligenter
macht oder auch nur dafür sorgt dass man
eine höhere chance hat einen nobelpreis
zu bekommen
vielmehr gibt es bei solchen
korrelationen oft eine versteckte dritte
variable in diesem fall ist das
vermutlich das bruttoinlandsprodukt oder
vielleicht sogar eher der human
development index länder mit mehr
wohlstand können sich sowohl mehr
schokolade als auch bessere bildung mehr
forschungsinstitutionen und mehr
grundlagenforschung leisten wenn man
diese kausalen also wirklich
verursachenden zusammenhänge erst einmal
versteht dann kann man auch allgemeinere
schlüsse ziehen und das gelernte auf
andere gebiete übertragen zum beispiel
weiß ich jetzt dass ich aufhören sollte
schokolade zu essen um intelligenter zu
werden und stattdessen in ein land
ziehen sollte das einen höheren human
development index hat ok aber was hat
das mit ki zu tun nun ein maschinen
learning modell macht oft nichts anderes
als statistische zusammenhänge zu suchen
und diese zusammenhänge korrelieren erst
an
nur wenn wir ein modell zum beispiel
beibringen wollen wie eine kuh aussieht
dann füttern wir dem algorithmus
natürlich eine menge bilder von kühl
jetzt stehen für aber meistens auf
wiesen oder vielleicht doch im stall und
es kann gut sein dass das modell bedient
die farbe die form und die struktur der
wiese mit dem konzept kuh zu verbinden
und das ist natürlich totaler quatsch
kühe stehen zwar gerne und viel auf
wiesen herum aber eine kuh ist genauso
eine kuh wenn sie am strand liegt oder
auf dem mond herumspringt oder auch wenn
sie lila ist und das problem sehen wir
auch erst dann wenn wir das modell
testen und ihm zum beispiel bilder von
genau diesen situationen zeigen
plötzlich erkennt der algorithmus die
kuh nicht mehr
denn der untypische hintergrund ist
negativ mit der präsenz einer kuh
korreliert und algorithmus hat nur
korrelationen gelernt keine
zusammenhänge verstanden
mit kühl ist das ja das eine wenn die
nicht erkannt werden dann passiert erst
einmal nichts schlimmes aber wir
verlassen uns in unserer gesellschaft
inzwischen in immer mehr bereichen auf
die algorithmen und diese korrelation
problematik schadet heute schon echten
menschen leben vielleicht das
bedrückende beispiel ist das der
criminal risk assessment al gore evans
diese tools werden in den usa bereits in
mehr als der hälfte der staaten
eingesetzt um die vielen verschiedenen
daten eines angeklagten in einen
einzelnen wert zu kombinieren
dieser wert soll angeben wie
wahrscheinlich es ist dass die
angeklagte person noch einmal
straffällig wird
je höher dieser score desto höher die
chance dass jemand rückfällig wird und
so zumindest die theorie
die hoffnung in den usa ist dass richter
mit diesem skore schneller entscheiden
können ob jemand eine geringere strafe
bekommt oder diese zur bewährung
ausgesetzt werden kann
die entscheidungen treffen am ende des
tages also immer noch menschen aber
dennoch cannes gezeigt werden dass der
caddy wert in knapp der hälfte aller
fälle von den richtern berücksichtigt
wurde menschen mit höherem risiko
bekommen längere freiheitsstrafen und
menschen mit niedrigerem risiko eine
kürze wird
das alleine ist schon sehr fragwürdig
diese eine zahl soll darüber bestimmen
ob und wie viele jahre im gefängnis
verbringen
aber wie dieser wert zustande kommt ist
noch spannender
im staat virginia wird der unter anderem
aus der art der straftat früheren
straftaten dem alter und dem beruf
berechnet und tatsächlich ist das alter
anscheinend eine der wichtigsten
variablen für eine rückfälligkeit je
jünger ich bin desto höher ist die
wahrscheinlichkeit dass ich noch einmal
straffällig werde denkt zumindest der
algorithmus menschen unter 23 bekommen
deswegen höre scores und daraufhin seit
einführung des systems im durchschnitt
zwölf prozent längere freiheitsstrafen
und sie wurden mit vier prozent höherer
wahrscheinlichkeit überhaupt verurteilt
im vergleich zu älteren angeklagten
dasselbe fahren man übrigens auch für
die farbe der haut heraus nachdem der
risiko wird eingeführt wurde bekam in
schwarz angeklagte 17 prozent längere
strafen
warum die maschinen learning algorithmen
wurden mit daten aus der vergangenheit
geführt und machen dann nichts anderes
als nach mustern in diesen daten zu
suchen
aber wie wir schon geklärt haben sind
diese muster erst einmal statistische
korrelationen nicht unbedingt
kausalitäten minderheiten die in der
vergangenheit von der strafverfolgung
überproportional stark ins ziel genommen
wurden wurden häufiger und härter
verurteilt und bekommt deswegen jetzt
schlechtere scores weil mit diesen daten
die algorithmen trainiert wurden und das
ganze system droht sich noch zu
verschlimmern weil nun neue verzierte
daten produziert werden mit denen
zukünftige algorithmen trainiert werden
können
[Applaus]
[Musik]
wie können wir einem modell nun also bei
bringen welche zusammenhänge wirklich
kausal sind und welche nur korrelieren
nun eine möglichkeit ist ihm unabhängige
faktoren zu zeigen
so kann das programm lernen welche
komponenten miteinander verknüpft sind
und wie genau sie sich unter einander
bedingen um zu unserem co beispiel
zurückzukehren
wir könnten zum beispiel die im
hintergrund die tageszeit die jahreszeit
oder die farbe der kuh separat variieren
und dem modell einige dieser bilder
zeigen in der welt des maschinen
learnings nennt man so etwas eine do
intervention wichtig ist aber dass das
etwas anderes ist als dem algorithmus
einfach hundertmal mehr bilder von kühen
zu zeigen denn bei echten bildern lernt
der algorithmus immer wieder die
gleichen muster also korrelationen im
zweifel wird hier der eindruck nur noch
verstärkt dass kühe immer auf wiesen
stehen und die wiese wird mit dem
konzept kuh noch stärker verbunden mit
einer do intervention hingegen erzwingen
wir dass die kuh unabhängig von ihrem
hintergrund betrachtet wird wenn es dann
gelingt dem algorithmus diese
unabhängigen faktoren beizubringen dann
verbessert sich dadurch seine sogenannte
robustheit seine robusten es bedeutet
der algorithmus wird besser darin zu
verallgemeinern als auch in unbekannten
situationen zu funktionieren und das ist
unglaublich wichtig denn wenn der
algorithmus das konzept nicht verstanden
hat und dann mal eine vor einem selbst
fahrendes auto läuft dann kann es sein
dass der algorithmus sagt was ist das
denn wo wir gerade drauf zu rasen
graf sehe ich hier nicht also kann es
schon mal keine kuh sein mehr forschung
getragen würde natürlich eher selten
kühl wir nutzen er daten selbst wie zum
beispiel frieden shapes objekte würfel
kugel in einem raum die können die
farben wechseln kann die größe wechselt
alles unabhängig voneinander
warum ist das und wie nützlich ein bild
ist erstmal einfach eine ansammlung von
pixel
jedes pixel hat drei farbwerte und für
ein computer ist das bild auf eine
riesige menge an zahlen wir menschen
gegen wir sehen ein objekt oder eine
szene und was wir da machen es einfach
mega kritisiert und das wollen wir euch
gerne dass der computer das lernt dass
das auch erkennt und dafür können wir
den daten zb free die chance nutzen und
diese unabhängig faktoren einzeln
variieren
und wenn wir das machen dann entwickelt
der computer ein gefühl dafür was diese
verschiedenen komponenten sind
und lernt dann zu identifizieren was das
ein objekt was die farbe von einem
objekt was ein objekt in einem raum und
somit eben ein symbolisches und
abstraktes verständnis für diese szene
zu entwickeln einem computer denn nur
aus einsen und nullen besteht dieses
abstrakte verständnis von objekten
beizubringen
also zum beispiel was ein apfel wirklich
ist das ist unglaublich schwierig aber
spannender weise befindet sich dieses
verständnis an einer ganz bestimmten
stelle wäre in der letzten folge schon
über auto in kohler gesprochen
also denkt oder der daten verschlüsselt
dann gibt es kompakte darstellung davon
und einen decoder der das gespeicherte
wieder entschlüsselt und da können wir
zum beispiel im bild vom apfel eingeben
und dann hat der autor dahin darstellung
von dem apfel und wir können das
probieren im ausgang oder beizubringen
dass derselben lernt das objekt es rund
das ist rot das hat ein stil und damit
so ein symbolisches verständnis und
konzeptionelles verständnis von dem
apfel hat das dem menschlichen sehr
ähnlich ist das langfristige ziel dabei
ist dass er nicht nur unabhängige
faktoren lernen sondern auch die
zusammenhänge zwischen diesen faktoren
wenn wir zum beispiel von einem baum
betrachten dann könne die jahreszahl
variieren aber die farbe des baums es
nicht unabhängig davon im frühling sowie
blätter grün und im herbst und im winter
liegt vielleicht schnee auf dem baum ja
und wenn wir jetzt ein verständnis von
diesen mechanismen haben dann wissen wir
auch dass wir ein haus sehen auf dem
schnee liegt das bild vermutlich im
winter gemacht wurde
das verständnis wurde also auf eine
andere situation übertragen und diese
transferleistung diese möglichkeit der
verallgemeinerung das ist das was unsere
algorithmen lernen müssen um eben von
dieser stufe 1 auf stufe zwei oder drei
zu kommen und auch möglicherweise contra
fachliche fragen zu beantworten wie was
wäre gewesen wenn ich finde das wirklich
mega faszinierend denn hier beginnt für
mich die magie des maschinen learnings
und tatsächlich auch so ganz langsam der
begriff intelligenz da fragt sich nur
wie lange dauert es dennoch bis das
funktioniert die forscher steckt aber
noch in kinderschuhen
dass wir diesen unabhängige faktoren das
funktion schon ganz gut wenn man jetzt
da die zusammenhängen lernen will wird
schwieriger und was das langfristige
ziel natürlich ist dass wir die auch
nicht vorgeben müssen sondern dass der
algorithmus selber lernt was sind nur
wenige faktoren was wird mich an dass
man dazwischen
das ganze dann helfen nicht nur muster
zu erkennen sondern auch zusammenhänge
zu verstehen und dann versteht auch der
computer was ein apfel ist verstehen
meint in diesem kontext übrigens erst
einmal ein rein visuelles verständnis
natürlich versteht eine ki die nur mit
bildern von äpfeln gefüttert wurde nicht
dass ein apfel in den kerner hat oder in
äpfeln vitamin c steckt und ich denke
mal dass das die diskussion um ware
intelligenz was auch immer das bedeutet
noch weiter befeuern wird simulieren
kann ist nur dass sie etwas verstehen
oder verstehen sie es wirklich zu diesem
thema haben annika und ich übrigens sehr
viel diskutiert als wir uns gemeinsam
den film ex machina angesehen haben
das wird übrigens einer der nächsten
folgen von wissenschaftler reagieren
und wenn ihr das nicht verpassen wollt
dann abonniert den kanal hier und
aktiviert die glocke damit ihr
benachrichtigt werden sobald wir dieses
video hochladen und ich hatte ja vorhin
schon darüber gesprochen dass es einen
ganzen forschungsbereich innerhalb des
maschinen learnings gibt der sich nur
mit fairness beschäftigt wie umfangreich
dieses problem ist haben wir glaube ich
anhand des beispiels aus den usa schon
ganz gut gesehen aber es gibt noch viele
weitere beispiele in denen ki
diskriminiert und für unfaire
entscheidungen sorgt welche das sind und
wie man kann wirklich fair gestalten
kann
darum geht es in der nächsten folge
unserer serie mit dem max planck
institut für intelligente systeme
falls diese folge jetzt schon online ist
dann könnte einfach hier klicken falls
nicht müsst ihr euch leider bis august
gedulden ansonsten wie immer vielen dank
fürs zuschauen und wie immer bleibt
neugierig patrick